[Music]
well new year new us that's gonna be
stuck in my eyes literally I heard it
just a double-check and I texted you
over break to be like look you wanted to
hear me you wanted to hear alive
yeah the songs out there amongst us yeah
but I want you to hear it live because
I've been sitting there for the last
three days going Jim Manson that's the
artistic part okay Jim and Sam Jim and
Sam yeah yeah I was a little nervous to
tell you the truth because literally
last night I saw somebody on video like
sending somebody on Twitter sending a
video their kids singing the Jim and Sam
theme song like it people it's so
engrained in people's heads
oh is it they original oh yeah nobody's
heard this version but then when I mean
the fact that I couldn't get it out of
my head and it's obnoxious it's even on
some of them more obnoxiously upbeat you
know I mean celebrating waking up in the
morning which especially working with us
you know I wouldn't mind one more run
through yeah just to hear it I wouldn't
mind just to give people really you sink
your [ __ ] teeth into it is again the
face plants out there in Canada
obviously a very talented group the same
group that made the original yeah
Jim and Sam theme song felt and more
correct to make an unnecessary sequel
that 2020 required a fresh new take Jim
and Sam and now I feel like maybe maybe
we get some play like the original theme
for best of shows and this is because
I'd love to have both themes just
ingrained in people's but I want to also
see which one people love the other one
and hate this one we'll use the other
one but if they if they take two this
one will keep this one I mean I think
all day a lot of people are gonna be
going Jim I hope so I know I will would
you like to hear it again I really would
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I mean I adore it I do too it's uh they
carry young and I learned they mentioned
Mike and Rob and Troy I loved that the
first time through
I liked it like the whole vibe is just
hey I know we take a couple make a
couple jokes here but we're all laughing
along - yeah you're celebrating wake you
up it's going to look at with your
friends Jimin saying our best friends
yeah yeah yeah I think it's a human
scent Jim ensign yeah you know this
needs with that it needs like a sitcom I
would your company went to entering
videos which emit like a panel for us oh
but all smiling this is a tease 100%
early 90s sitcom theme but everybody's
smiling and laughing I was thinking the
exact same thing the first time I heard
it remember we did all that like when
serious was like oh we need an intro
footage for our app and like you walked
in the door like all happy and took a
pause for everybody to clap for you
there should be one of us like laughing
like Jim met like the handover just
good-natured good all good-natured right
like you know just a little just ribbing
going on yeah yeah yeah it's best
friends who wake up in the morning and
we're performing yes celebrating the
hilarity but good job man thank you for
doing that and it's a great job
the face-plants welcomed us into 2021
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM a/v